[Music]
hey everyone and welcome to a quick
little update update 1.1 i guess i'll
name this one and um check my latest
updates obviously if you want to stay
like in sync with what i'm doing here um
so what i've decided to do in this
update is just tell you guys that a lot
of my older videos that i recorded with
cam studio actually had a lot of audio
problems and my mic was like glitching
and like all framing and staticky and
everything so i upgraded to camtasia
studio six so now i have actually much
much better vis uh actual video quality
when i actually produce my videos in
camtasia studio six and before i was
using movie maker and cam studio and
somehow that just didn't work out so now
i'm going to be using um camtasia studio
six and hopefully my problems are
totally gone if you watch my last few
tutorials they got thousands of views
and they had no mic problems so that was
really really great
so um that's basically the first thing
and the second thing is that yeah well
i'm gonna be recording re-recording my
older videos that didn't have as many
comments that i'm just completely taking
out
and i might even delete them i'll just
leave them up if you guys still want to
watch them but they'll have the same
description and links and everything but
they'll be better more in depth more
focused
and really a lot more professional
basically so that's basically what i
have to tell you guys in update 1.1 and
that's basically it thanks for watching
guys and uh sorry hope you enjoy my
tutorials and stay tuned and subscribe
for more and there's a lot more to come
if you have a request you know obviously
the drill so subscribe to my page and
just go ahead and send me a request or a
personal message or something and i'll
definitely get back to it and i got a
whole long list of requests i got to do
for you guys so thanks for watching
peace
you